these cells are dividing in a very
unusual way
without replicating their dna
when we first saw it we are not sure
whether what we saw is real because this
is not how we know of cell division from
the textbook but it was real
a team of scientists have discovered a
whole new previously unknown kind of
cell division
and they even have an idea of why this
textbook busting event happens
normally before a cell divides it needs
to duplicate all its dna
so that each new cell gets a full copy
so over the past
180 years since the cell division has
been first described
only two title of the cell divisions has
been extensively studied these two types
are mitosis and meiosis
but unlike both of these in this new
form of division the cells don't make
more dna
they split up the dna between them but
neither cell has a full copy
chen and his team noticed this unusual
division when observing skin cells in
tiny zebrafish larvae
the team were able to colour each
individual skin cell
and these fish are so small that they
were able to track what happened to each
cell we want to understand how skin
cells
may work together to enable animal
growth while tracking the cells the team
spotted the unusual cell division some
skin cells can undergo two runs of the
cell divisions without the dna
replication
not only once but twice the cells were
able to divide without replicating their
dna
and they seem to be in a bit of a rush
the team noticed the cells were making a
lot of mistakes
sometimes the dna wasn't separating
cleanly between the new cells
sometimes bits of dna were almost
getting left behind
and sometimes the cells gave up on
dividing altogether
so why were these cells skipping the
crucial step of replicating their dna
before dividing
well chen and his team believe it may be
a way to make sure that enough skin to
go around when growth is fast
we think that this division is that
temporary and measures the animal use to
expand on their body surface
in fact after a few weeks the zebrafish
got rid of these unusual cells and
replaced them with regular cells
with the normal amount of dna that you'd
expect
this brand new type of cell division
raises many questions
we've got an idea of how it happens and
why
but how widespread is it
and is it present in you and me
because we
see this unique cell division events
in ziba fish which is a vertebrae
species i think that's a possibility we
might see semi kind of division in
humans
you